I like to appeal to my family to my wife
subra and my sons junaid Ibrahim is my
heel and my daughters Xena and Maria I
like to peel them please please contact
with me and please please call me at
least it's been it's been eight nine
days you're out and we don't know where
are you i miss you i love you all of you
i love you a lot I can't live without
you I like to my family please please
call me at least I know where are you
are you safe and especially my feels old
son it's my heat and I'm worried about
my daughter's all both daughters but all
family and I like to them please call me
please respect engineered Jeanette your
pure 15 please please if you watch this
video please ring me please contact with
me I love you I love all of you and I
can't live without you I don't know
where are you I don't know are you and
mari especially Maria please Maria you
know Maria I love you I don't know what
to say I'm shaking and I miss you too
spent too many days I don't know where
are you please please come back home so
we can live normal life please
please come back home it's nothing wrong
please come back home nothing at the
nothing wrong i miss you that's all i
want to say i want them back please